en direct avec stéphanie gibeau auteur
du livre la traque de lanceurs d'alert
préface est justement par julian assange
bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin d'abord votre
réaction à l'annoncé du verdict du
tribunal britannique m'écouter faire
jouer les deux les deux prêts les deux
interviews vous venez faire c'est à dire
que la fois c'était une date qu'on
attendait tous quelque part avec
beaucoup d'impatience et beaucoup
d'anxiété donc effectivement on est tous
très soulagés il ya beaucoup d'émotions
et puis la deuxième chose qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'effectivement on peut
remercier tous ceux qui soutiennent
julian assange depuis des années qui se
sont mobilisés un notamment à londres a
ajouté qu'on peut penser aux étrangers
qui n'ont pas arrêté de faire des
déplacements devant la prison de bell
marchés et à tous ceux qui sont
mobilisés depuis les depuis des années
donc effectivement c'est un énorme
soulagement et on est tous en train de
maintenant se poser la question de
savoir ce que vont faire les états unis
est ce qu'ils vont faire appel au pardon
et quelle va être la suite du coup de
donner un à ce dossier mais en tout cas
l'un pour pour ce matin en tout cas
c'est la meilleure nouvelle avec
laquelle on pouvait commencer l'année
2001 on va parler justement de la
réaction des états unis mais on sent
dans votre voix
dans votre réaction beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion qu'est ce que vous ressentez
exactement vous qui êtes un as lanceur
d' alerte et qui suivait ce combat de
julian assange depuis des années en fait
on est sur des problèmes si vous voulez
qu'ils sont des problèmes liés à la
fraude droits de l'homme
alors bien évidemment la liberté de la
presse à la liberté d'expression
mais avant tout ce sont ce sont nos
droits humains qui sont bafoués dans ce
qu'on appelle démocratie occidentale
donc en fait avoir à se battre à ce
point pour se faire respecter pour faire
faire respecter l les droits de l'homme
et la liberté de parole la liberté
d'expression pour soutenir une presse
libre et indépendante quelque part ça va
ça va même au delà de l'entendement
c'est à dire que on a l'impression
d'être dans un monde qui marche sur la
tête ou plus rien plus rien n'a de sens
donc là c'est une décision qui justement
donne du sens dans nos histoires de
lanceurs d'alert qui n'avait plus de
sens depuis depuis des années donc ça
redonne l'espoir que la justice peut si
elle le veut être être étiez qui
allaient dans le sens des citoyens
en tout cas cela ressemble à un
camouflet pour l'instant pour les états
unis
vous parliez justement de la réaction de
l'administration américaine on sait
qu'un passage de relais très bientôt et
on se souvient que sous le mandat de
barack obama joe biden était
vice-président et la justice à l'époque
avait renoncé à poursuivre le
cofondateur de wikileaks votre avis
là-dessus puisque le passage de relais
ce très bientôt le 20 janvier entre
donald trump et joe barton mais c'est
pour ça qu'on arrivera à une situation
extraordinairement
complexe à savoir soins l'administration
et le président un train décide à ce qu'
il ya eu ce qu'on appelle que croiser
une donc pas redonné un sens j'ai
d'enlever toutes ses poursuites
c'est bien là où on aimerait justement
entendre la voix du président puisque je
vous rappelle que dans la préface de mon
livre est écrit non pas par dieu lune
assange à la citation est la suivante le
président trop me disait alors wikileaks
donc angoisses qu'elle en est
aujourd'hui avec ça avec la décision
aujourd'hui de la justice britannique
elle est susceptible d'être
soumise à un appel a donc ce n'est
peut-être pas encore terminé on le
rappelle julian assange il risque aux
états unis cent soixante quinze ans de
prison
voilà tout ça pour avoir imprimé
la vérité c'est pour ça qu'en fait ce
dossier ça concerne forcément la
personne kate huling assange est l'homme
qu'il est mais ça concerne tous les
citoyens ça concerne tous les
journalistes tous ceux qui se sentent
non concernés par la liberté de la
presse et la liberté d'expression parce
que sont qu'un peut effectivement être
un c est un cas d'école et savoir si
effectivement il avait être extradé aux
états unis d'autres d'autres
journalistes pourraient à l'avenir subir
un subir le même sort donc c'est
tellement important que l'on doit tous
mobilisés pour en comprendre les enjeux
on verra bien comment l'administration
du futur président américain joe biden
réagira par rapport à cette affaire et
vous l'avez rappelé julian assange a
préfacé votre ouvrage la traque des
lanceurs d'alerté
il y déclarait la vérité finit toujours
par a gagné il est en train de gagner
son combat d'où la naissance fond il est
en train de gagner le gagnera c'est
clair puisque on arrive à une époque à
un moment de rouler les esprits
s'éveille
les gens commencent à comprendre
justement l'intérêt de la vérité
l'intérêt de savoir les choses qui nous
ont été cachés et les enjeux pourquoi
est ce que nos gouvernements nos
administrations là on est en train de
parler des américains
pourquoi est-ce que autant
d'informations et caché des citoyens et
que on arrive à un ras-le bol
internationale
est ce que le dossier des changes juste
le dossier d'assange pardon est
justement le révélateur que tous les
citoyens quelles que soient leurs
nationalités sont concernées par la
liberté d'expression par la liberté de
la presse et pas reconnaître
les informations les gens ne sont plus
naïfs ils ne veulent plus laisser
endormir à tous les niveaux donc je
pense que la décision qui est prise
aujourd'hui il suffit d'aller d'aller
par exemple sur twitter qu'une heure
pour voir
l'avalanche de tweets qui arrivent de
toute la planète pour se rendre compte
qu'en fait là il ya une convergence de
tous les citoyens pour faire bloc et
pour savoir la vérité et pour protéger
justement les gens qui osent se lever
pour la dire parce qu'il faut beaucoup
de courage pour dire la vérité
c'est un sujet dont on a peu parlé mais
les lanceurs d'alert sont des gens
excessivement courageux parce qu'ils se
retrouvent tous complètement isolé et le
cas assange est en train de montrer que
justement pour un homme tout le monde
est capable de se lever donc ça donne
vraiment beaucoup d'espoir pour le début
de cette année 2021 merci beaucoup à
vous c'était l'année un gigot je
rappelle que vous êtes un auteur du
livre la traque des lanceurs d'alert
préfacé par julian assange merci d'avoir
témoigné en direct sur un défense